foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell joined by
Jay borshaw this hour and we're excited
to take your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money well Jade I want to kick off the
show with a correction to a call I took
yesterday many of you reached out thank
you for that and we took a call from
Angela and she had a HELOC she wanted to
use a 401k loan to pay off the HELOC and
so we're walking her through why this is
a bad idea and the advice remained that
she shouldn't do it but my explanation
of why was incorrect that's all right so
I want to make sure that we educate our
folks out there on why the 401K loan is
a terrible idea
so the idea here is I'm going to take
money out of my 401k and pay myself back
with interest of you know five percent
right already not tracking because you
have to use your own money to pay
yourself that interest right right the
big issue here is that you're unplugging
all of the growth of that money compound
interest was working for you you know
the S P 500 average rate of return 10 to
12 since 1928 yes and so you were
missing out on all of that growth which
is only going to hurt you down the line
in retirement
number two it puts you in a very
precarious situation because now we're
dependent on our employer because if you
leave that job for any reason you get
fired you switch jobs that loan now
becomes due the IRS sees that as a
withdrawal so now to do within 60 to 90
days you've got to come up with all this
money or else it's a withdrawal and now
you've got a 10 penalty your tax rate on
top of that adds insult to injury
so it's a very very scary situation and
to make it worse you're using after tax
dollars yeah come on George to put the
money back in because you're using your
net income to repay the loan and
interest and so it's a very tax
inefficient way to put money into your
401k and so I know people feel like
they're backed into a corner my only
option was to borrow from the 401K you
have other options
and the debt snowball works and most
people they go for the debt
consolidation they go for the HELOC in
times of need your emergency fund is
there to prevent you from having to go
back into debt that's right ever again
and so that's why we we tell you to get
to baby step three with gazelle
intensity to avoid that mistake I love
that yep maybe steps one through three
are all about the intensity so you can
avoid situations like what George just
mentioned absolutely so there there's my
correction I apologize for getting that
wrong yesterday I will try I'll tell you
it won't happen again but I'm a fallible
human being and I wish I had all of like
the wikipedias in my head but sometimes
you know in a radio show you're doing it
live and uh you slip so apologies to
Angela and to the listeners out there
we're going to do better for you what
kind of guy is this come on George
listen this is what I'm talking about I
love the Integrity I love it thank you
thank you well let's get to the phones
Michael awaits Us in Fort Lauderdale
Michael welcome to the show vote Lottie
hey how you doing doing great how can we
help
uh So currently
um just looking to become more
financially independent uh I've been
taking great strides ever since getting
out of college I'm 29 now
um
own a house it has about
210k on the note left
um
have a car loan of 35k on that end but
the home itself uh is now worth
I would say close to 760k wow that's
great yeah so I I mean I uh bought it
for 310
um when I was 24
and put another 180 into Renovations
into it and um so you know it's got
Equity there oh my God I I currently
have about
370k and in stocks and as well as bonds
um single stocks
uh yeah single stocks okay
um I'm currently
making a career change at this current
moment as well
um you know I was making roughly around
180 to 200 000 a year working for an
employer
um
I'm actually switching careers to the
construction industry going to take 100K
pay cut basically uh to learn and
basically learn that industry in order
to eventually open up my own thing so
I'm kind of in uh in between Crossroad
paths right now so how can we help you
today
I mean right now I had a vision of
then I guess biggest thing is my home
was either to sell it or I was going to
convert it over to an Airbnb just
because of another Financial investment
opportunity for me
um and that's really where I'm stuck do
I sell it take the equity and pay off
the no and take the equity and
potentially go invest in something else
or put more towards stocks or my future
career I mean you've got a lot of
options here for me the first thing I'm
going to look at is getting clearing out
all of the debt and making sure that
you've got a the right amount of savings
in place so you mentioned having the
370k in stocks do you have any liquid
money any liquid cash just sitting
around that would be you know usable for
an emergency fund
uh so liquid liquidity wise I have about
35 to 40K okay
so so you can pay the car off today yep
so you're saying to pay the car off
today yeah and then your next goal would
be have three to six months of emergency
fund and I would sell enough stocks to
do that and long term I'm selling
obviously you need to look at the tax
implications and do this wisely with a
tax professional
but I would sell those stocks and bonds
and put it into index funds and mutual
funds instead
because you can lose your butt in an
instant with that kind of volatility
so that's one way to keep the wealth
that you've built you've done an amazing
job
and you're talking about you want to be
financially independent which means your
money makes you money more money than
you make that's the goal right to where
you have cash flowing assets through
your index funds mutual funds real
estate and I want you to do that all
without debt and so your goal would be
if you sell sell this place to buy
something that's reasonable in cash
would be an awesome goal
you know I agree with what George is
saying wholeheartedly but I will say it
kind of feels like you're trying to do
the most like you're trying to do
everything you've ever heard of to do at
one time and I think that if you kind of
just slow down a bit and lay out all
your cards on the table and go okay let
me make sure you can still get to where
you want to go we want to make sure you
get there the wisest way and I think
just kind of slowing down and looking at
what your scenario is where you
ultimately want to be and then just
taking those Steps step one by one to
actually get there and I agree with
George getting that debt cleared out and
if you want to sell the house fine
taking that money buying something else
in cash making sure that you've got that
great savings uh three to six months
saved up in liquid cash and also also
clearing out those stocks for sure and I
would be working with a financial
professional if you're not already you
can connect with a smart investor Pro
ramseysolutions.com and one thing to
think about is focusing on tax advantage
retirement accounts and not just that
brokerage account with those stocks
because that's another way you're able
to really build wealth down the line the
brokerage account can be a piece of that
puzzle to help you retire early and be
financially independent and you're on
the path man but one way to do it stay
out of debt and build wealth and use all
of that income your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income use it
maximize it you're on the path my friend
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five well about
this time of year we get flooded with
calls on the Ramsay show because
everyone's looking for a fresh start
with their money so if that's you you
can't wish for things to change and just
expect it to happen you've got to do
some different things with your money
and have a plan and we teach you that
plan in Financial Peace University
this is the course that will help you
rethink how you manage your money you're
going to learn our proven plan to beat
debt and build wealth plus you'll have
access to our financial coaches to help
you every step of the way nearly 10
million people have now taken FPU
followed this plan and changed their
lives and you can do it too today's the
perfect time to start that's because
right now we are offering FPU get this
just 69.99 that's wild but it's only
through the end of the month so time is
running out here this year you can have
more peace in your finances and your
life don't wait get this limit time
offer on FPU at ramseysolutions.com deal
that's ramseysolutions.com deal I don't
know George I think some people need to
make the move today like they gotta go
to they have good reason to and it's
because you have signed up to lead a
virtual Financial Peace University class
and you're trying to like break a
Guinness record here yes most amount of
people signed up look you know before we
started working here at Ramsey my
husband and I we coordinated classes all
the time and so I know what happens when
you have the right amount of inspiration
the right amount of motivation the right
kick in the pants that you need to get
going and I'm hoping that by
coordinating this class people will feel
that and they will really start to
change their lives I mean look you don't
need to be in my class to change your
life but if you have the opportunity I'm
just saying you should take it so I am
coordinating a class and that class
starts March 1st so if you are on the
interwebs and you can see this little QR
code I want you to click the code I want
you to sign up we're meeting twice a
week all I'm asking George is for one
hour of your time for each of those
nights so it's just two hours a week
five weeks five weeks it's accelerated
it's accelerated it's super fast maybe
in the past you've heard of a nine week
class or you know nine-week course we're
gonna do this thing in five weeks you
are going to be a supercharged like you
know like what is that anime where they
like power up you're gonna just be
powering up on financial peace financial
literacy guys we are pumped and you're
excited you're doing this from your
house you are going to get an insight
into the home of Jade Warrior I cannot
wait you might see my son we're gonna
see what you want for dinner it's gonna
be great don't ask me what I'm eating
for dinner George it's gonna fire the
people up if you're listening and you're
like well what is this QR code hey you
can go to this link you can always pause
it and write this down fpu.com one one
five nine six one one one one five nine
six one one and I'll just add in a lot
of you guys have probably signed up for
FPU before but I'm not trying to put you
on blast but you never opened the course
you never click Start if you did that
you can still join my class you just
have to choose it as the one that you're
joining as long as your FPU is still
valid so yeah accountability is the key
and I feel like Jade's the kind of uh
instructor coordinator that will call
you out by name if you're not there yep
Phil Smith did you do your budget
Jim Jones Phil's not there he's getting
called out so I love it if you I feel
like this is the year we go listen
buying the thing isn't enough we need
the accountability yes I don't have
friends and family that is on this
journey with me that's right we are here
for you we want to be those
accountability Partners bring some
friends along for the ride too it'll be
a blast I love it come on George let's
go all right let's go to the phones
Jonna joins us in Medford Oregon John
welcome to the show
hello how's it going
good how are you doing great how can we
help today
um okay so I'm 19. my husband is 21 and
we live with his mom and I just found
um your guys's podcast a couple weeks
ago and so we're trying to follow the
baby steps but I'm a little lost because
we have like so much debt and we want to
buy a house we want to get out on our
own but if we were to follow them in
order we would be paying off to for
years until we were able to buy a house
so I just I don't know what our next
step is well how much debt do you have
well we have 2400 that we owe his boss
and then our car loan which is 19 000.
so those are both doable but then we
have a hundred and nine thousand from
his restitution okay and what's your
income
together make forty five thousand
both of you together what are you guys
doing for work right now
um I just started a job about four
months ago and I'm house cleaning and he
is a chef Chef are those both full-time
or part-time
um his is part-time mine is full-time
but he's looking for we're starting to
look for a better paying job for him
okay cool so total Consumer Debt on
paper you're looking at about a hundred
and twenty thousand hundred thirty
thousand here
yeah okay what's the restitution
payments like
how does that work um is it a certain
amount of time certain monthly payment
not really I mean we can pay it off for
the rest of our lives if we want but we
were doing we've been falling behind but
we were doing just a hundred a month and
I never thought I thought this would be
something that like we would pay off
until we're old until I found you guys's
show and I was like okay maybe this is
possible it's absolutely possible you
can absolutely do this
um here's the thing you guys are 19
you're 21 you're just getting started in
life your newlyweds you're living with
the parents
um you've got time so I want to start
out with that you know sometimes it
feels like we've got to do everything at
once we got to move out we got to get a
house we got to get debt free but I want
to just kind of
just remind you that y'all are just
getting started you're you're all right
we're going to give you a plan to get
through this and I think it starts with
number one your husband getting
full-time work and getting that income
up and even with you you're cleaning
houses
um is there anything you said you were
working for a company cleaning houses is
that correct yeah um if you can pick up
doing some of that work on the side for
yourself to get your income up so that
we can start to tap into this debt a
little bit do you guys have any money
saved anywhere
no we don't no savings all right what's
the car worth
I I honestly don't know it's a 2014
Buick Verano I would do some homework to
see if that's worth you know you need to
save up some money to get a beater car
but if you can sell that thing for 19 or
20 and get out of this car loan well
then we can just focus on paying off the
boss real quick and then we just have
this restitution to deal with and we're
going to attack that thing with a
vengeance that's right so do you think
that we should pay off the restitution
before we start looking to buy a house
absolutely I think that you know the way
that we teach is by a series of baby
steps and we teach it that way it's been
proven over 30 years this method works
it's helped millions of people get out
of debt so the way we teach it is that
baby step one is that you're getting a
thousand dollars saved so when you get
off this call today you need to get with
your husband what's his name
Xander you need to get with Xander and
tell him hey thing one for us is we've
got to get a thousand dollars saved
quickly and that can look like you
selling stuff that can look like you
picking up extra hours whatever you need
to do to get a quick starter emergency
fund because that's going to give you
just a little bit of peace all right and
then after that you're going to start
working aggressively to pay off all of
your debt using the debt snowball method
are you familiar with that
the smallest ones that's right that's
right so that's here's the thing baby
step two it's not it's not a lot of fun
right George and it takes it takes that
intensity it takes people some time to
get it done but you can definitely do
this
and your journey may you know be a
different one for Jade and her husband
they had almost half a million dollars
in debt it took them over seven years
yeah and for you guys it may take you
know four five six years to get rid of
this restitution but it's going to be
the wisest way to become a homeowner
down the line and you will become a
homeowner down the line I gotta tell you
this and I'm glad that George brought it
up Donna my husband and I we rented we
did not purchase a home together until
we were 33 years old
all right so it takes time and then you
know you look at the other baby steps
and you think oh my gosh I don't have
enough time I'm running out of time
that's not true you have plenty of time
even if you don't start baby step four
until you're 35 walking this plan in
order is ultimately gonna be what's best
for you you're gonna have the best
financial footing you're going to be
able to look back and go oh my gosh we
did this and one day you'll have a house
one day you keep walking the steps
you'll be baby steps millionaires just
like so many people and you're gonna
have an incredible testimony to share
with others at the end of this road and
share your debt-free story hang on the
line we're going to gift you Financial
Peace University I want you and Xander
to go through this even better join
Jade's virtual five-week class she's
starting in March and that will light a
fire under you to get rid of the debt
once and for us we're cheering you on
Donna this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 off everything site-wide
go to blinds.com for more information
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsey personality George Campbell
joined by Jade warshaw we're taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to the phones
Andrew joins us up next in Des Moines
Andrew welcome to the show
Hi how are you doing great how can we
help today
so my company's offering a one-time
election change to my retirement
benefits So currently they fund uh fund
a pension for me at four percent of my
salary and then it gains interest based
on the 30-year treasury note and then um
they also fund 10 into a 401k account
they're proposing to stop funding the
the four percent into the pension and
just add an extra four percent to the
401K and then the money that's in the
pension fund would just continue to grow
at that interest rate and then I'd get
14 into a 401k plan so I was wondering I
guess what your thoughts were on maybe
which option would be better to choose
or stay with or man if I woke up in your
shoes I'm switching over to that 401k
okay
instantly
yeah you're going to have better returns
and more control
and so those are just just two reasons I
like it because that pension uh when you
die it goes bye-bye that 401k you can
pass down generationally that's right or
if something happens with the company a
lot of times a pension is what what goes
away as well yeah and the companies are
obviously the reason they're doing this
is they're getting away from having to
manage these pension plans and the whole
world except for some you know
government sectors are switching over to
401ks so I'd make the move that's a
great uh benefit they have absolutely
that was kind of the yeah
but it's not a mandatory
correct okay so with this situation how
much are you contributing from your
paychecks
uh six percent okay
and could you bump that up now to 15
percent
uh um my contribution up to 15 yes
uh I could probably go up to 10 based on
circumstances my wife and I are
expecting our first child so kind of
just so exciting that is exciting you
guys have any debt
uh I got some business some side
business that I do work on the side so
how much debt do you have on that end
around oh 100 000 or so whoa what's your
business bringing in the side business
uh bit I farm on the side cool
well I would focus I mean that that dead
has your name on it at the end of the
day and so I'm I'd be focused on getting
rid of that and even looking at pausing
contributions I mean they're already
putting in 15 so if you went is that a
match or are they just putting in 14
regardless of what you put in
14 regardless wow man that's amazing is
it a Roth 401k
or is it
I I think it's I think it's uh pre or
traditional yeah I think I think it'll I
think it'll be taxed when it comes out
so okay okay
cool well I'm focused on getting rid of
that debt on the side business and then
I'm ratcheting it up to 15 which you'll
be able to do uh once those payments are
out of your life do you guys have a
mortgage as well
uh no cool do you want to be a homeowner
someday is that part of the plan
yeah
cool what's your income
uh around 130. is that including the
side hustle uh no so with the side
probably maybe around 1 170 or so very
good awesome well I'd focus on using all
of that side of money to throw at the
debt on top of however much margin you
can scrape from your uh full-time job
income
sure yeah I just try to keep the
business side separate so I haven't
taken my personal anyway over there but
yeah it's something I could do cool well
you have money in the bank for the baby
uh yeah yep good that that's what we
would call kind of the storm and Stork
mode where if you need to pause the baby
steps temporarily pause investing pause
debt payoff make minimum payments if you
don't have enough cash to cover what
could be we just don't absolutely you at
least want to be able to cover that
deductible because you know it's going
to cost you that yeah look at that max
out of pocket yeah and that gives you
some peace of mind when you get some
medical bills at the end of this but
hopefully everything goes well with the
baby congratulations man it's exciting
awesome all right let's move on to Kathy
in Saint Paul Minnesota Kathy welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call I am I
bought a cabin about a year ago my
husband and I are both 70. and uh we
don't have any depth our house is paid
for
um we have about 700 000
um in Investments it's all Diversified
and um our house was worth five hundred
thousand and we want to spend about 250
to 300 000 on it's going to be a simple
cabin I just don't know where I should
take my money from if I should do a home
equity loan or take out some of the
savings
the money that you have the 700k is all
of it is that just a combination of
401ks and IRAs
yes and that's I'm you said 500k was the
house so 200k in that on all that
retirement fund
the the house is worth 500 000. okay and
I'm saying of the 700 it's 500 of the
700. or is that on top of it so you got
700 in retirement oh it's on top of this
what's your income right about 7 000 a
month okay and what's that made up of
um are um
Social Security and our like I have a
pensions we he's a pipefitter and I was
in the Army and we have those two okay
do you have any liquid together seven
thousand cash yeah
and you do you have any cash in the bank
that's liquid yeah we have about 20
grand okay so we'll call that your
emergency fund we won't touch that yes
well looking on paper my only concern is
that if you guys I don't want you taking
a HELOC or doing anything like that
um that that puts your home at risk
which at your age I don't want you guys
to do when you're in retirement age
and so the question is you don't you
don't advise a home equity no never no
no and so the only way you I would
advise doing this is if you wanted to
take that money from your retirement
accounts and use it on the cabin you
could do that here's the caveat are you
going to have have enough money in that
retirement account to live for the rest
of your lives
that's right that's my question because
don't I use the bank's money though when
I do a home equity I'm using their money
but you're leveraging your your personal
Residence at the time of that which you
right there's no need for you to do that
Kathy you guys have to no one should do
it but you guys have way too much money
to to to go that route
okay you don't need to put that kind of
risk in your life are you guys able to
maybe just rent a cabin for a while
every time you want to go over there
oh no we bought this this kid I mean we
have a cabin there but it used to be a
chicken coop so you said you bought a
cabin but you're going to spend 250 on
it is that in renovations is it yeah
it's going to be yes it's gonna be
either new build
we we don't have that setting stuff did
you buy the land is that what you're
saying because you keep saying you
bought the cabin
yeah we bought six acres on a lake in
Wisconsin it's got a little tiny
run-down cabin on it we paid 150 cash
for it okay and so you're wanting to
renovate this cabin essentially or build
something new or build something new
next to it real simple okay are you
working with a financial advisor right
now or an investment professional
we we have a financial advisor and she
told us to do a home equity loan credit
you need to fire your financial advisor
Kathy yeah yeah I don't like it I want
you to go on to ramsesolutions.com and I
want you to click on the trusted
services and I want you to get with
somebody who's going to a have the heart
of a teacher and help you through this
because you've got the money to do this
you just need an investment advisor to
kind of help you see how you can access
that money without you know with the
least amount of hit to you and make sure
that you're okay in the future since
this is your big nest egg and Kathy the
way I look at this if you have 700 in
retirement let's say you take 200 out
for the cabin that leaves you with 500
in retirement so if you take a a
conservative withdrawal of four percent
that's twenty thousand a year it's about
1600 bucks a month plus the seven you
guys are bringing in from Social
Security and pension right
right so the question becomes are we
okay for the rest of our lives living on
eighty six hundred dollars
does that sound good to you
yeah 8600 yeah yeah well it reduces your
risk you'll have no payment because
you're not taking out any loans and so
that's the route I would go but I would
first consult with one of our smart
investor Pros to maximize the wealth
that you guys have built before we jump
into this dream of of having the cabin
but I'm pulling for you guys I hope we
can make the numbers work and hope you
guys get to live that cabin dream real
soon thanks for the call this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
ER to the show and you want a deeper
dive on what we're all about what are
these Ramsay baby steps what is my next
step well we have a great tool for you
at ramseysolutions.com just click on the
get started button and we will figure
out what the right Next Step for you is
on that Financial Journey based on where
you are today that's ramseysolutions.com
and click on get started open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Kyle is up next in Baton Rouge Kyle
welcome to the show
hey how are y'all doing doing great
what's going on with you
years ago my wife and I am 25 we bought
our first home and uh hurricane came
through and we didn't have a good
coverage for our roof because it was the
age of it so
um we got an SBA loan uh it's about ten
thousand dollars three years deferred
payment uh one and a half percent
interest right now I'm contributing 20
to my 401k and where we're saving we
have about 20 grand in savings my
question is should I I just got a raise
we're making about 140 collectively
um should I increase how much I'm
contributing to my 401k lower my taxable
income we get more money you know in the
long run seven ten percent uh stock
market or should I focus on paying down
this SBA loan
great question Kyle well we'll give you
the short answer which is I'm paying off
that SBA loan today me too okay and then
you'll still have you know what half an
emergency fund left over and I would
also lower the 401K contributions for
now and you guys are 25 you got plenty
of time there's other goals you guys
need to save for right are you you your
homeowners now
yeah yeah we are homeowners now first
kid uh back in September awesome that's
great what's left on the mortgage
uh 220
cool
yeah and I mean we're maxing out both of
our IRAs and and work trimming about 20
20 to the uh 401k and she says that I
saved too much but you're definitely
doing great on the saving side do you
guys have any other debt other than this
ten thousand dollar SBA loan no no
student loans no credit card
um
she is a car loan that's like 3 000 that
I could probably come on
paid off today I mean wouldn't it feel
good wouldn't it feel good to free up
the payments regardless of what's going
on with this interest rate
yeah that's true it's just the mental
jump of seeing the money go I guess yeah
but man you make 140 for you to save up
13 Grand with no payments in the world
you're going to do that in a heartbeat
lickety-split sure and so that's I mean
that's the Ramsey plan it's the same
plan that Jade and I followed to build
wealth and there's just nothing like it
and on paper you know you can justify
and argue and go well the market well
the market lost like 18 percent
so correct there's no such thing as a
guaranteed I'm gonna make seven to ten
and my loan's only 1.5 man when you get
rid of that debt that's a guaranteed
return right there that's right so and
you had the money this isn't even a lot
of work for you this is like a few
clicks right
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I no I appreciate that input
and then I'd work on so if you if you
brought your Investments down to 15 of
your household income uh you'd still you
know get close to maxing out the 401K
and do you have a Roth 401k
I put five of the
so it's really only 15 too traditional
okay yeah I would for the future I
wouldn't convert anything but for the
future contributions I would go all Roth
at your age man with compound growth
withdrawing all that money tax-free and
retirement you see a million bucks in
retirement you actually get a million
dollars tax-free
right and so it's and you don't have to
worry about you know what are the tax
implications going to be what about my
income tax bracket you just you pay the
taxes today and you don't worry about it
and then focus on paying down that
mortgage how quickly could you pay off
220 making 140 with no payments give me
a give me a year estimate
two years eight years yeah
two years do you think so dude if you
I'm telling you if you bring your
investing down to 15 you make 140. could
you not you know throw close to 100 a
year if you're you don't have any
payments and your income continues to go
up
yeah that'd be a cool goal two or three
years the house has paid off what's your
mortgage yeah yeah uh right now it's
1300 but I'm paying uh 15. okay
cool well I would I would bring your
investing down to 15 and then ratchet up
the extra on the mortgage and I mean by
the time you're you won't even be 30 yet
you'll have a paid for house and you'll
be maxing out every retirement account
you can get your hands on for the rest
of your life oh that's a dangerous man
right there seriously that's dangerous
right there I like it I'm proud of you
man
thanks yeah I appreciate it but listen
y'all recommended
oh well we appreciate you listening in
love just young people getting hold of
this stuff Jade going oh my gosh I don't
need to wait till I'm 50 or 60 to
hopefully have a paid off mortgage and
hopefully do this stuff yeah make a
great income they're doing the right
things once we get this debt gone and
you already have that savings muscle
that investing muscle right that's that
was his superpower right there and it's
I I get it he saw that 20K saved and it
makes you think oh I have security here
but it's a false sense of security when
you have savings but you have debt that
outweighs the savings especially
absolutely all right let's go to Miami
Florida that sounds nice this time of
year Kevin how's it going
hey there I'm doing real good thank you
for having me it's quite a surprise
really you're surprised to get on the
air
yeah
hey don't let any Kevin's through but
Jenna was very kind to you today what's
going on thank you
well um I'm calling because I'm kind of
in a like a good comfortable situation
in my life like I have some money saved
um I actually own the place that I live
in now and I'm just trying to you know
kind of ask what do I do with the little
money that I've saved up I have a couple
um well I have a couple different like
assets but I have a little over 30k
uh probably maybe 40.
um and I'm just trying to ask you I mean
I'm 27 and I just really don't know what
to do with the money because it's in a
couple different assets but what kind of
assets
um so I have
about 19
000 in uh the stock market and that's
just Diversified in spy and like spy
growth how are these in they're not
single stocks they're index funds or
ETFs yeah I know I have a couple of I
have a couple single stocks that I
checked this morning and it's only about
maybe two thousand
um in single stocks even like small cups
so I actually am debt free with credit
cards and everything like that I've
actually never missed a payment with
that but I have about 8 900 in the
student loans
and uh I do have a car lease that is
expiring at the end of this year are you
gonna give it back or buy it out
oh no I'm gonna give it back I have no
interest in buying it out they always
like you know risk you off oh you
already got ripped off a man they made
their money oh yeah this is you're not
coming out and then some like a rose on
this one
yeah it was three it was 290 a month so
I didn't feel like it was too bad
considering the whole Corona thing okay
so you're gonna need a car at the end of
this do you have money to buy a car
yeah so so um I also have
um a little over I will I'm I'm about to
hit about 9 000 in the savings okay
um and then I also have some Assets in
gold and silver that are actually up a
little bit how much could you sell that
for
um to be honest I don't really want to
sell it because it's like my like my
second savings account almost like
like
I don't know like I think of it as like
my second retirement account I'd rather
you I mean you're gonna make way more
money in the stock market than you are
hanging on to the gold and silver
I mean if you look at the return on
these things over the years
so it's actually up over a thousand now
I bought it
last year when it was about 17 something
on spot price but George is talking
about long term man I want you to
military I want you to build a real
wealth long term so you got the student
loans any other debt once this lease is
out
no and I I am considering paying it my
struggle is that because I live in the
place that I own and there's no interest
occurring on the uh student loans I have
trouble rationally paying any of it even
at the moment until they reenact the
interests on it that's that doesn't make
any sense you you want to take advantage
of the fact that it's interest-free you
don't want to wait until there's a fire
for you to get out of the house you need
to get out you need to get out of that
student loan house now I'm cashing out
of these stocks yes um and I'm cashing
out of the silver and gold honestly and
I'm getting rid of the student loans
we're gonna buy a used car with cash and
that makes you completely debt free with
some money in the bank uh so that's
that's you call this show you're gonna
get our advice that's our advice we're
sticking to it you can build wealth a
lot of ways we just have chosen this
path because it works every time man
thanks for the call this that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show in the books my
thanks to Jade warshaw and all the folks
in the booth and new America thanks for
tuning in we'll be back real soon
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
staying from the PODS moving and storage
Studio it's the Ramsay show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money I host
Jane borshaw I am joined by George camel
we've got a great show for you guys
today hey be sure to call and say the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'd love to take your
calls about your life and your money and
hey if you're a new listener and you
want to just dive deeper into the things
we teach the Ramsay baby steps Ramsay
principles check out ramsesolutions.com
and click that get started button we
want to help you figure out what the
best best next step is for your
financial Journey based on where you are
today that's ramsesolutions.com click
get started and hey one more thing if
you like this show can you consider
liking it sharing it passing it along we
would love if you did that it cost you
nothing let's go to the phone lines
we've got Tim from Jefferson City what's
going on Tim
hey how y'all doing we're doing good
what's going on
so my wife's been uh talking about Dave
Ramsey uh you know for a long time
recently sold our house
um
100 out of debt uh because of that
we have six figures sitting in the in
our savings account and I am just
terrified to do anything with it I know
what I'm supposed to do with it based
off of what y'all teach
um but I'm upgraded to the point where
I can't even tie the church
um we both make a good living
I I just I don't know where this fear is
coming from and I don't know the right
next step in order to get out from
behind this do you think it's because
you've just never seen that much money
sitting in an account at one time you
just don't want to mess it up is that
what it is
no I never I never had any money I was
never good with money until I met my
wife uh and we we got married she took
over finances
um she was I mean she's been she's a
phenomenal saver
and we've been been close to that in the
past
um but I've always just bled money and
now that we have no debt and I have two
kids
and I don't know we're both as good off
as we've been in our careers
um so what do you think the right next
step is if you were to use this money
today what would it go towards
I don't I don't know we both have good
cars we have a roof over our head that
we're running
um our kids all have nice clothes
how much is it I don't know
how much is what how much is the the
amount sitting in the account
okay
so with the next step for you guys you
have is that include your emergency fund
in that hundred thousand
that's that's uh
yeah that's close to everything we
probably have like 110 total okay okay
so aside from the emergency fund your
next step if you want it to be is home
ownership and using that money as a down
payment
right are you guys investing currently
yeah my wife has a 401k and I have my
Roth
um and we both have pensions with our
with our work and that's the thing we're
in the military and we don't know how
many moves we have left
so you're moving every few years so
you're like hey let's just rent and
we're going to be here for two or three
years we're gonna move somewhere else
let's keep renting
so correct is essentially I mean like
what George said you've got if you can
kind of separate the the six months of
expenses because in your case I would
keep it at six months and then just uh
make sure that because then for all
intents and purposes you're at this
point on baby step four if you're
investing 15 and you're not quite ready
to buy a home yet or go you know go on
to a further step you know after the 15
invested you can just sit on that money
for a while make sure if maybe in the
next five years if you have a plan you
know to maybe purchase at that point let
it sit in a high yield savings account
for a little while but if you know hey
this is like I'm in the military or this
is our plan for a long time more than
five years then it might be smart to get
with a smart investor Pro and see if
it's worth investing that money so that
you know you can gain on it and gain a
great interest rate
how does that sit with you
it makes sense it's just scary I don't
know why I'm just afraid to make money
moves look here's the thing look at
where you're at now I feel like you're
kind of stuck in the past on all this
stuff that you did in the past and
that's that's dead and gone look where
you're at now you have no debt you've
got paid for cars you're living in
you're renting you're making good
choices and you got a virtuous woman
next to you who's helping you make good
choices you're sitting pretty dude yeah
I'm married off you married up you just
rest in that you're doing good this is
not all on your shoulders to decide
where every penny goes this is a marital
decision we're making as a team based on
our shared Vision our shared goals and
like Jade said you don't have to make
any decisions today that's the beautiful
thing it can sit there I would rather it
sit in a high-yield savings account
which is by the way going to be you know
FDIC insured the money's safe up to 250
000 per person on the account and so
you're good this money's not just gonna
disappear you're not going to go to
Vegas tomorrow and so I'm sleeping
better at night instead of worse I know
that's right and and you're the one who
called in the show you you made choice
so let put that since you're keeping
score it sounds like on your good
choices versus bad choices put a little
check box next to the fact that today
you made a great choice and tomorrow
you're going to make good choices and
the next day and the next day you're
doing good and you're doing real good
there's only three things you can do
with that money Tim you can give it save
it and spend it you mentioned you're
having a hard time even letting some of
it go but there is such beauty and
freedom in having an open palm and going
you know what I'm going to give a little
to my church to the offerings above
tithe I'm going to give a little to an
organization we're going to do that
regularly we're going to allocate some
of this for a vacation or a cool
experience whatever it is and then the
rest we can go we're just going to keep
saving and that helps you feel a little
more balanced versus leaning one way or
another feeling out of control yeah
that's right that's a good call you know
I think people face that a lot you know
when you've had this background where
it's like oh my gosh I've never done
good things with money I just make all
these bad decisions and then before you
before you know it George you look up
and it's kind of like wait a second I
did something right and then you did
another thing right and then you did
another thing right before you know it
you are good at money well and there's
such wisdom in having a little bit of
that caution and fear when it comes to
having that pile most people are gonna
go sweet a pile of money in the bank
let's go spend it let's go get an 80 000
car uh instead Tim's going we worked
really hard for this and I've never been
in this position and I'm just a little
bit nervous and over time you're gonna
get more comfortable being in this
financial situation your incomes are
going to continue to go up you're going
to continue saving you're going to start
saving for your kids future education
and college you're gonna that's right
pay a house off one day and so this is
just a milestone in the journey so
celebrate it have a plan for it budget
it but don't lose sleep over it either
that's right and you know another good
thing about that that call that I kind
of want to call out for other people a
lot of people sell their home and it's
like okay I've got this money sitting
here and and the Temptation is to want
to invest that money because you think
oh if I can just put in the stock
yeah well they want to invest it and
think that maybe they can get you know a
bigger return but they want to buy a
house in the next two to three years and
it's kind of like the market did what it
did last year you're hurting for certain
you didn't make money with your money
invested and that's we talk about the
stock market being a long-term game a
long-term mindset and over time
consistently we've seen you will make
money in the stock market but if you
have the mindset of well I just don't
want it sitting in a savings account or
checking account so I'm going to throw
into the stock market that's a recipe
for disaster if you're jumping off the
roller coaster too early my friends it
sure is and you're going to be a little
bit disappointed at what you find so
yeah Park that money and a high yield
savings account and uh when it's time
you'll have a nice little Nest Egg saved
up there this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshaw this is George Campbell
sitting next to me and we're taking your
calls America triple eight eight two
five five two two five call in with your
questions we've got Madeline here on the
line from Atlanta Georgia what's going
on Madeline
Madeline hi guys how are you we're doing
good how are you Madeline oh it's
Madeline it felt like a matter of time I
do really yeah you get the vibe oh no I
love it well first of all I want to say
my husband and I he's here listening um
we're we've been following you guys so I
want to safely say since what like
August of last year um his
brother-in-law my brother-in-law's
brother told us about you guys and we're
like yeah you know but then we finally
like dabbled so here we are
um I'm glad you're here
well thank you thank you um we have a
very what I guess everybody says your
situation is unique but ours is unique
to us
um I'm I just turned 30 my husband's 35
and we have three children from eight
just turned three and nine months nice
and we were looking at purchasing our
first home and then going the
traditional route and then that's when
we discovered that my husband
um Anthony actually does not have credit
his credit score is a zero and then the
only debt that he has is probably
totaling up to maybe 3 000 Maybe
um just and you know just personal
things here and there that we could
honestly knock out with like a paycheck
and then with me I just have student
loans and then a vehicle from a previous
relationship that's actually kind of
tied up in a court situation so that'll
take care of itself within a little
while so technically I only have student
loans
um we've been going through the baby
steps and why we did uh do baby step one
and start on baby step two both of our
children needed some dental work one
needed braces one had to get you know
cavities so that's what our savings went
to but I was a little upset but my
husband's like that's an emergency fund
and that's what it's there for okay so
we're building back up our savings and
you know we're probably maybe 500
towards the 1500 Mark okay because I've
never heard of anybody not having credit
or like I guess surviving this long if
you will with no credit cards or nothing
yeah and again my husband is the only
one working because we don't see the
point of child care at the moment so I'm
taking two years off because I was also
working full-time okay
um so how can we help you to know we
just want to know what is the direction
that we should actually go we're in a
position to where we can either turn
this into a really great situation
because we technically don't have a
whole lot of debt or we can just Fubar
it well I thought I heard
I thought I thought
of the student loans in the 3000. well
that's what I was getting to because I
could have swore I heard you say there
was 3 000 and there are student loans
how much are the student loans so my
student loans total up to 32
000. okay um I've been making payments
on and on and then uh on and on and I'm
currently in a forbearance period that
is scheduled to be up I have to look but
I think I come out of forbearance in
June okay
um so we're going to start making
payments on those can you make payments
earlier
um I definitely could yeah and what does
your husband have student loans or just
you
um no he does he doesn't he paid his way
through school because he's smarter than
me so 35 000 of debt total
total okay so you know what I'm gonna do
Madeline is I'm walking through the baby
steps you already started that process I
don't want to skip ahead I don't want to
do anything out of order
um so you had your starter emergency
fund of a thousand dollars do you still
have that I know the kids had to get
braces and whatnot do you still have the
thousand dollars there
uh Court to act the middle of February
we will as long as we stick to our
savings plan okay so we'll get baby step
one done once that's done then we're
going to start attacking your debt using
the debt snowball and we're just going
to do smallest to largest so we'll knock
out that little 3K deal first the 32
after that and we're just going to
snowball it you got to get intense with
those payments uh what's your take-home
pay between you and your husband
combined
um combined we're looking at probably 62
62 000 a year okay are those student
loans I'm only like I'm very I'm a
stay-at-home mom my husband works
full-time okay so are those student
loans are they broken out into smaller
loans or is it one giant okay well
they're broken out into smaller loans so
the biggest loan that I have is actually
23 and then the other there's three more
that kind of just what's the smallest
one the smallest one I have is 500. okay
that's the one I want you to focus on
and that's your only goal you're going
to make minimum payments on all the rest
of those loans we're just going to
attack the smallest one with a Vengeance
with all the margin we can create
through our budget through spending less
and making more and that means that home
ownership is going to be on the back
burner for a little while because we
have to clean up this 35 000 then we
need to have a fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
then we can start saving up the down
payment for the house so this might be a
few years away
gotcha and that's what we were talking
we were talking about we wanted to push
for it but at the same time we're like
one with the market being the way it is
and then two with us as being like a one
income family we don't necessarily want
to put ourselves in a situation where
we're like oh we can't afford it but
then it kind of messes up our savings
and everything else you can afford it
until reality hits and life happens and
then you need to do the braces again
because they screwed it up and then the
HVAC goes out and you thought the rent
was going to be equal to the mortgage
but it turns out there's property taxes
and insurance and Home Maintenance and
repairs and you can feel the weight of
what that would be like in your budget
so that's right I'm pausing on this and
once he gets there once you get there
and become completely debt free the
emergency fund uh of course he's going
to have no credit score if he pays all
this off make sure all those lines are
closed and you can do what's called
manual underwriting our friends at
Churchill Mortgage do these all the time
I went through this process myself it's
called a no score loan yep I did it and
it works every time and you you're gonna
need to have 12 months of rental history
if you can consistent on-time payments
you're going to need to show that you've
paid your insurance bills on time every
month your cell phone bill is on time
every month your utility bills every
time on on time every month and if you
have those types of things in your life
Churchill Mortgage will look at you like
a real person like before credit scores
existed in the 80s that's right and they
had to go yeah you guys have the income
to afford this you've got no debt so the
debt to income ratio is amazing and you
have money in the bank for the down
payment yeah we'll give you the loan
it's a great call Madeline thanks for
the call let's take a look and see
what's going on here with Nidra Nidra is
here from Washington D.C what's going on
Nidra
hello
um hi I was calling because I'm married
but my husband and I recently married
maybe like three years ago okay and
prior to him meeting me he was already
close to retirement so he has his
savings and he has all that going on all
of that so with me I
um I make 16 16 31 bi-weekly and what
I'm trying to do is find a way in order
to save
and to get myself out of debt so I'll
make 1631 bi-weekly and after I get paid
I don't have anything left I can't
control how much that you have
um I have uh I have a large amount of
debt how much
um total debt I can give you well my
school that
um is 70 000 okay and I have my my car
note is 8
604 dollars
and then I have
um credit card usage
um I have one account for 434 dollars
and the other one is for four four
thousand 474 dollars okay and then then
I have like a um Bob's Furniture I had
purchased some furniture because we had
just purchased a home so I wanted some
new bedroom furniture and we got that
and that's a balance of fifteen hundred
thirty eight dollars
so Anita I'm confused you said you got
married but this sounds like you're on
your own in this world uh-huh yes is he
not well combined have you guys not
combined bank accounts is he not part of
this debt payoff thing no he he uh he
said he did not want to combine and how
does that make you feel
oh pretty bad
whoa wait when he married Nidra he
married all of Nidra didn't he does he
know that yeah
yes here's what I need you guys got to
get on the same page with this because
when you get married is no more me and
you it becomes ours and you're not gonna
get far even even Nidra if you do this
all by yourself there's going to be a
rift and there's going to be a problem
there because you guys are not one so I
do want you guys to uh get with a local
Pastor I want you guys to get with a
counselor you've got to
um get on the same page about this
because you're gonna start feeling
resentful how much money does he have in
savings does he have liquid cash
you said does he have liquid cash yeah
how much does he have like just cash on
hand that he can get to
um I think he has some money saved maybe
like 9 000. well we got to get away from
guessing and wishing and hoping and get
real numbers and if he's not willing to
share his bank account with you I'm not
sharing a bed with him I know that's how
this works this is marriage it's what he
signed up for yep you guys got to work
together and until you do I still want
you to dig into the baby steps walk
those baby steps out in order but Nidra
do not let this go untouched all right
this resentment will crush the
relationship over time as you're clawing
and scratching on your own it sure will
I want you to work on this all right I
need you don't forget about it and don't
try to do this by yourself this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more births
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show and in the lobby
of Ramsay's Solutions on the debt-free
stage we've got Keaton and Liz they're
with us how you guys doing so good
excellent where are you guys from we are
from Dublin California Dublin California
so you're here to do your debt free
scream I want to know tell me everything
tell me everything how much debt did you
pay off so 39 053 18 cents if she wanted
me to say it was 18 cents we'll get you
that's right in 11 months wow 11 months
what was your income during that time
range of income it ranged monthly from
about 4 800 to about 9 000 at the end
wow wow what do you guys do for a living
so I work as the director for a house at
Chick-fil-A in Pleasanton right next to
Dublin and the Bay Area and then I also
work at Chick-fil-A with him that's how
we met yeah a love story surrounded by
chicken I love it blessed chicken yeah
there's plenty of them too by the way
like so many people meet there it's
awesome oh really that's amazing well
they hire amazing people so the quality
of the people they're like why look any
further you don't need a dating app just
go to your local Chick-fil-A I love it I
love it so what happened that you know
kind of sparked this journey and what
made you want to pay off all this debt
39 000. that's a great question I was
looking into Ramsey Solutions before we
got married I knew that we wanted to do
it the right way and so really we
buckled down together as a couple about
two months into our marriage like
February March time frame
um but beforehand I was like I'm gonna
pay off my car quick and then right
after that we started paying off hers oh
my gosh so what was the stat two car
loans two car loans but one was already
paid actually so just one during the
actual debt-free Journey like the 11
months was a concentrated effort effort
for me like we buckled down multiple
times throughout the program and each of
those times like okay I'll sell the
Robin Hood I'm not making money did that
hurt did it hurt what would you have it
in what were you invested in single
stocks or crypto singles yeah they were
up and they were down um but you'll only
lose when you sell and I just I had to
lose because I had to submit to the
program okay you know
he had to submit to the program
swallowed your pride and ate a little
stupid tax but was it worth it do you
miss your crypto and single stocks I
don't no right decision but yeah we had
uh credit cards the car loan
um debt to my parents which was actually
kind of like half student loans and then
my own student loans as well wow wow wow
wow so you guys are young how are how
old are you guys 24 24
years old newlyweds you just start
getting crazy you start you start
budgeting you start going where people
like oh my gosh the people that you
worked with your family wasn't did
anybody think you were crazy or were
they on board with you
um a lot of people just had questions
like why is this so important what are
you doing it for like what's your reason
so it's cool to kind of give our like
reason behind it and kind of get other
people motivated to do it as well
especially some of our friends what's
been the feedback from your friends as
you've been telling about this journey I
think it's been like they're impressed
like they're inspired the hardest part
was not so much friends for me but
family because no sorry can't go on that
vacation no I know you'll pay for the
travel but it's a loss of income I'm
trying to work 55 hours a week yeah so
wow wow and you're you've you're alive
to tell the tale because fomo is one of
the big reasons you know the kind of the
YOLO mentality of well I'm never I'm
only going to be 24 once yeah you want
me to miss out on that vacation so I can
be working 55 hours a week right but
instead you guys said well if we
sacrifice for a short time 11 months
it's Gonna Fly by like that yeah we can
be free for the rest of our life yes sir
I was surprised by how quickly it went
at the beginning it felt like it was
going to take forever and we kept having
to say no but then at the end of the
year I was like oh my gosh that happened
so quick now we can like go on all these
families it's kind of crazy to think
about we won't grind like this like ever
again because we're not gonna go back to
that situation ever again that's right
oh man I love that just a short-term
sacrifice yeah for a long-term gain I
love that so what's next for you guys
what's next on the docket this whole
year we did like a little vision trip we
called it where we planned out what we
want 23 2023 to look like and for us
it's trips you know it's enjoying our
youth now that we had paid off all that
debt like we can create some more margin
yeah and so we'll have the emergency
fund done by the end of the year but
we're also going to make time to invest
in moments together uh since we didn't
do as much of that in our first year
marriage yeah wow I love it I love it so
for anybody listening who's your age
newlywed just getting started what would
and then they've got a mountain of debt
what would you tell that person what
would you say to them
um I think definitely sticking to the
budget it's hard at first I remember all
the conversations we had a few tears
were shed and I was very stressed out
but try to stick to the budget like as
hard as you can I know it's like really
hard to be rigid about it but do it
because it pays off and you honestly
like kind of learn habits and then you
just kind of keep them which is like
really nice um that's really good yeah
and it was family meetings for us too
where we could share some of that
motivation we would check in with each
other each week and talk about all sorts
of things but finances was always one of
them yeah and like sacrifices we were
gonna make and yeah once you use that
snowball you start rolling the debt
forward it was crazy to see how much
steam we could pick up and like how
excited we got like I remember in
September we paid off 8 000 worth of
debt in just one month which is double
our pacing yeah and like after that
we're like all right we're almost there
three months to go here's the home
stretch yeah and you learned so much so
much about each other right as husband
and wife you kind of pick up on each
other's ways of communication good
habits bad habits so which one of you is
the spender and which one is kind of
like the saver or are you both I think
we're both naturally Savers I have my
seasons though where I like want a new
pair of shoes or something like that but
um yeah I think we're both naturally
Savers and then I do most of the
shopping so he doesn't have to stress
about it for like groceries and all that
so it kind of stays away from that yep
that's smart well you guys are I feel
like you've matured already as newlyweds
just going through this process and
having to adult and go like oh crap we
gotta pay the bills and we have to pay
this debt off we can't keep relying on
Mom and Dad or the white house or
whoever to get us out of the mess we got
in and that level of personal
responsibility you mentioned you've
created these habits now that will stick
with you the rest of your life and carry
you as you build wealth yeah absolutely
it was really good to build that um
independency from like parents and stuff
and just kind of start off like our
marriage strong we did a premarital
counseling
um with his like God Parents and they
helped us lot with the financial stuff
too so it was setting boundaries too
yeah I think that's what she was leading
into which we would definitely want to
encourage any newlyweds out there that
are starting to navigate these
conversations to have confidence and
always start out with we love and
respect you Mom and Dad but we're taking
charge we're we're setting our
boundaries for a reason where it's our
money and we're using it uh the way we
see fit and I wish I had a tear if I was
your parents going like I raise the
great kid oh man I love that that's a
good point George like in the moment
they were not happy about like our
decisions we made but down the road like
the respect has come back and that's
such a gratifying experience and seeing
how proud they are yeah that is so great
guys I'm so proud of you and uh we've
got you know our live and give it box
for you it's the next step in your
journey it includes a copy of Total
Money Makeover you can give that to
somebody so that they can learn the same
process that you did to get out of debt
and change your life and build wealth
and it's got a couple a copy of baby
steps millionaires in there and a year
of FPU so make sure you take that home
with you but
the next part is my favorite part guys
all right get ready to count it down
we've got John well I'm sorry we've got
Keaton and Liz and they have paid off
thirty nine thousand fifty three dollars
eighteen cents in 11 months making 4 800
to 9 000 go ahead and count it down guys
okay three three two one
[Applause]
proud of them I'm especially proud when
Keaton was like we just had to tell our
parents yeah what it was we had to put
those boundaries and I don't know if it
was their parents or Chick-fil-A that
instilled just such a wonderful
respectful manners but that was my
pleasure to to share their story with
everyone on air I'm sure it was their
pleasure as well George that is exciting
I mean it just it just goes to prove
time and time again that these steps
work it works baby step two you know
it's not easy George you know you got to
put your head down you got to forget
about all the voices out there telling
you what you're doing is crazy well you
know why don't you spend your money like
this do you really have to go so hard
but you know when you do it you end up
on the debt every stage and they started
changes they went oh we can control our
income we're gonna go from 4 800 a month
to 9 000 work on our tails off yes and
all of a sudden it takes 11 months
instead of years control guys you can do
this whether you're 23 or 43 it's not
too late for you debt freedom is
available but you gotta reach out and
grab it and do the hard work that's
right I'm proud of them you guys did a
great job this can be you to America all
you have to do is submit to that plan
and you could be standing on this
debt-free screen stage doing your debt
free scream all right this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
to the Ramsay show we're taking your
calls about your life and your money you
can give us a call today the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
and it's a new year thank you Lord and
that means man you can't be given up on
those goals that you set out to
accomplish this year and if your main
goal is to build those money muscles but
you've only been to the money gym once
like everything else man it's time to
make progress and stop making excuses
now I know it can be hard when you don't
have a plan or you're starting out with
000 of debt like my husband Sam and I
did but if you want a practical proven
plan to climb out from under those piles
of bills and start Building Wealth grab
yourself a copy of The Total Money
Makeover man this book is literally the
reason that I'm here today guys it's the
reason I'm sitting in this seat this is
Dave's best-selling book for a reason
you'll learn the seven baby steps to
guide you through your journey with real
life stories from people who don't have
to struggle with money problems anymore
because they followed the steps and you
can too let's be real with you paying
off debt and Building Wealth it it's
it's not just for those people out there
guys having Financial Peace is not just
for the people on TV it's for you the
people in this book did it you can too
so get back on that money treadmill and
order your copy of The Total Money
Makeover today at ramseysolutions.com
store you got this all right let's go to
the phone lines here we've got Sally
from Columbus Ohio what's going on Sally
okay I have a question
um I am in between Vehicles cars and
I've taken over my mom has a fleece so
until she's done with that in September
we're sharing her car so I dropped my
insurance when I got rid of my car and
so when I called the insurance company
to drop it they said well you can't what
are you driving and then they had me do
some type of insurance where I pay like
55 it changed because it was 40 it was
forty three dollars and now it's 55 now
that and then she has full coverage so
do I carry the insurance or do I not
you're saying now that you've switched
over to your mom's car your insurance
has gone up because you're driving her
vehicle essentially
no they said I have to have so I have to
carry some type of insurance
driving her vehicle even though she
carries full coverage
so my question is do I carry it or do I
drop it have I contacted has your mom
contacted her own insurance company
um we had a boat we I think she issue we
both had the same insurance company okay
and the car is listed under both of your
names
um it's her car so like I said it's the
fleece because we live in the same home
because she's you know we live together
um I just don't know if I should keep
the insurance are you living in the same
household as her
yes okay
um they should be if you're in the same
household and you're of legal driving
age you should be on the same insurance
as her so I would say if you they can
just add your name to her insurance
that's what we did we borrowed my dad's
car we were not in the same household
but it was as simple as us adding our
name to his policy while we were
borrowing his car
Okay because I'm going to get one once
your car is done but there's no stuff
they have in your car so I'll eventually
get my own and then she won't have
nothing
but then if she has to drive mine she'll
have she could be on Monday or at my car
yeah if that's the case if you're going
to be sharing each other's cars I would
just have both of your names on each
insurance
to make sure you guys are protected
hopefully that helps you out Sally you
want to make sure you have the best
insurance and make sure just in case
anything happens all right let's take
another call let's talk to Stephanie in
Rochester what's going on Stephanie
hi guys how are you today we're doing
good how are you
good I have a question so my husband and
I are in the fortunate position we're in
baby step number six awesome we own a
property where he manages his business
or where have a mortgage on a property
where he runs a business and then we
have a mortgage on our house and we're
in the position where we can pay off one
or the other
um which one do you guys recommend what
are the balances on the mortgages
well the mortgage and the business place
is about 89 and some change in the
mortgage on our house is about 95 000.
and we have about 125 set aside oh I
love that that is that's great that's
great so you've got to pick up the
letter here with yes and the only caveat
with it is is for his business we plan
on putting addition on at some point and
we'll cash flow it
um so I don't know if that changes which
one you pay off first
not really you know in this case
business debt it it gets rolled into the
debt snowball as personal debt so in
this case I would place that ahead of
your household you know your personal
residence and I kind of would have
treated that business debt like it was
baby step two so I would go back okay
and use the money for that is this the
only money that you have or do you have
an additional three to six months saved
we have an additional three to six month
days okay then it sounds like you could
we we keep all the business money
separate from our personal so this is
just the money we have for the 125 is
just the excess we've been rat hauling
to be able to pay the balloon payment
off that it would have been at five
years but we'll be at three years on
February 1st yeah I mean I get the idea
of keeping the money separate but at the
end of the day I mean it's your money
and it's affecting your personal finance
so that's why I would have thrown it
into baby step two the good news is
you've got the money to take care of
that and if you wanted to start chunking
away at your you know personal residence
you can do that too how does that sound
sounds perfect yeah with 125 in there
you can knock out the business mortgage
at 89. you'll still have 36 left to
throw at your primary which has 95 left
and that brings your total debt down to
one primary residence with a mortgage of
59. what's your income
um well it changed a little bit this
year
um but last year we were at like 225.
amazing so you can knock out this
mortgage yeah within the year yeah so
either way with the next year they're
all gone oh yeah by the time oh I love
the sound of that I don't know about you
Stephanie but that just made me
extremely excited for you how do you
feel about it
I'm excited I'm a we have three little
kids so I'm actually cutting back my
hours to be present for the kids more so
this makes it you have options yeah what
are the payments on those mortgages
um the one for the business is I think
2500 a month and then their personal
mortgage I think the base is 1500 but
we've been paying 2 to 2500 every month
so you guys are about to get a 50 000
yearly raise because you freed up four
grand a month just like that
wow and that allows you to have those
options
to cut back work less stay home that's
the that's part of the plan that people
forget about if you have so much freedom
and options when you just get out of
debt completely and you have an
incredible income like you guys do
that's exciting man Stephanie I would
love it if you sat down with your
husband and you guys really think about
what you're gonna do with this new life
that is so exciting to me you know I
hope that you uh take this advice man to
be debt free George by the end of the
year of two mortgages or personal
mortgage and a business that's amazing
That's so exciting and then they're
gonna be able to cash flow whatever they
want a cash flow they are people forget
about renovation vacation if it's got
Asian in it they're doing it Asia come
on George I'm gonna coin that I'm gonna
put the little TM right next to that
thank you that is great that's an
incredible couple oh man all right
George you want to take another call
here do we have time it may be tight you
know let's shoot the breeze a little bit
okay because well I want to talk about
this people forget in that situation
that we just talked about the freedom
that you get from paying off the debt
they had what is this 125 000 sitting
there that they could have said well
this is Cushy this feels nice and we're
making the payments it's fine but we
want to do something different we want
to get free and when you start looking
at those numbers it's just it's really
something how your life can change and I
don't think enough people take the time
to really dream about what their life
would look like with no payments well
the the emotion side of it is hard to
put on paper and so you kind of get
comfortable in your situation you can
afford your payments and you think this
is what life is supposed to be and yet
we also see you know sky high levels of
anxiety and depression across the
country oh yeah and that has been rising
with debt and so it's hard to not make a
correlation and go debt is causing us to
feel this pain not all of it but a large
part of it is finances when you get that
freedom in your life it's easier to have
the margin to focus on other areas and
focus on your physical health and your
relationships because you have the
margin to do it that's right that's
right I mean we know that it's what you
said George 37 of Americans say that
they're struggling with Finance we know
that people are living paycheck to
paycheck but you don't need to do that
you can be free from your money and
we're here to help you do that so ladies
and gentlemen that does it for this
week's episode for this today's episode
um and I want you to remember this you
can tell me that you won't do it but
please don't tell me that you can't do
it because when it comes to your life
and your money all things are possible I
know that's right this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsaysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm your host Jade
warshaw and I am joined here by the
amazing the incredible boom George
Campbell last time you were illustrious
I don't know what happened there oh we
went down or not it's fine we're taking
your calls today you can give us a call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'd love to take your questions
find out what's going on in your world
what's going on in your life we're going
to do that with Carly she's here from
Chicago Illinois what's going on Carly
how can we help
I I was I'm certain nursing school in
April and I was really just wondering
how do I pay my way through college
I love it
nursing school in April so do you know
how much it's going to cost
it's gonna be a little under 40 000
because it's like a two-year accelerated
program and forty thousand total over
those two years
yes okay so twenty thousand a year and
what's your what's your current income
are you able to work while you're going
through the nursing program or yeah I am
I'm still able to work about full time
because I can do like remote work if I'm
not able to come into the store where I
work and I make about like 35k a year
after taxes
so that's your take-home pay and do you
have any money saved right now
um I have like 2 000 saved up okay
that's not a bad place to start so I
love that you don't want to take out
loans and that you've taken loans off
the table that's that's thing one right
George so at this point it's really just
making sure that you are paying your way
through now you know I think that with
your income let's see how much
disposable income after all your bills
are paid and after everything's done
what do you have left at the end of the
month margin wise
about eight hundred dollars all right so
there's there's where we're gonna have
to pick it up just a little bit because
we got to pay twenty thousand dollars a
year on this thing
yeah when are those payments actually
due
um I have my cell phone bill which is
due at the beginning of the month and
same with the loan I have right now it's
just a personal loan I got like a year
ago when I first turned 18.
I think we're talking about the the
college the how how you're Jewish yeah
when do you have to pay your tuition is
that is 20K due in April when you start
oh no they do like payment plans and at
all they said I can choose like what
date I want in between
what like what date in the month okay as
long as you have it paid by what's the
deadline point
um I have to have three grand saved by
March 23rd about okay and is there an
urgency to jump into this program is
there something where maybe we could
pause stack up cash and then start it in
the fall
they do like it's like quarters so they
do like April and then there's one like
starting at the like in the summer and
then there's one starting in like the
fall too oh great yeah I mean it's great
there's options here you don't
necessarily have to start you know here
coming up in April because the fact is
you don't have the money yet and if you
need 3 000 to start I want you to have
three thousand dollars in cash to to
start I don't want you to have to go
into debt at all to do this so if I'm
you I I would put this on hold and get
your financial situation in place get it
a little bit more firmly planted so that
you can have the money saved up and if
you wait you know if you decide that hey
you know I'm gonna wait a full calendar
year or I'm gonna wait till fall you
might have more than 3 000 saved up so
you're feeling even more comfortable
about this how does that sound to you
it actually makes a lot of sense and it
also gives you time to really research
are there any scholarship opportunities
grant opportunities my employer offer
tuition assistance is there another
employer where I could still work
remotely make more and they offer
tuition assistance so I want you to just
have some breathing room to dig into all
of that and do some homework so that we
can cash flow this thing and you can
graduate completely debt free as a nurse
I love that plan you know I love that
she's wanting to go to school but I love
that she wants to do it debt-free but
sometimes you got to put those things on
hold yes hang on the line Carly I'm
going to send you our best-selling book
Debt free degree it'll walk you through
all of the options give you some
creative ideas and give you some
confidence in this plan so hang on the
line we're going to get that book over
to you I love that thanks for the call
Carly let's go over to Odessa Texas
we've got Courtney on the line Courtney
what's going on in your world
well my dad passed away
um a little over a year ago and
um he left me some property and I'm just
coming curious what you guys advice I
should do with that wow I'm so sorry for
your loss how old was he
um he was in his 50s wow
that's tough
that is tough so tell me a little bit
about the situation you know you said he
left you a property what type of
property is it is there is there what is
it just land tell me about that um well
it's it's a few properties
um one is just it's five lots and it has
some
like kind of run down
um trailer houses and then it has a few
um
like uh RV camper kind of things on it
and then
um two commercial properties and then
another uh property that is like seven
lots and that has like four houses on it
wow wow what is all of this worth
combined
um I'm not 100 sure
um in regards of like a total amount but
I'm guessing somewhere around maybe
like with the commercial properties I
think those are maybe a hundred and
thirty thousand and then the
land is probably I don't know maybe a
guest man around like 20 000 and then
the properties
um that have the houses on it
um
I think that my Dad paid like just it
was like 15K for it and so it's probably
appreciated in value some but I'm not
sure exactly how much so like maybe like
165 170 for for a lot of it
that's what I'm thinking somewhere
around is any of it cash flowing
currently
no okay are you wanting to hang on to
this and deal with it or would you
rather just sell it all and use that
money to propel your own Financial
Journey what excites you more
any mortgage or anything I just have you
know like the utilities and the property
tax annually so that's great do you have
any debts
um I do have some student loan debt but
I'm working on paying that off so how
much debt do you have left total
um right now it's at 36k all right and
what's your income
um I make about 38k a year okay so what
if you worked with a real estate agent
and said hey for now I'm going to sell
one of the properties and clear my debt
and get that fully funded emergency fund
in place would that make you feel better
to free up a payment you can have that
pile of money there
I think it would definitely I would
start there and as you feel comfortable
start selling more of it off unless you
love a piece of it and it's cash flowing
well then hang on to it but you know
this is a legacy that's left for you to
manage and I think your dad would be
proud for you using it to propel your
financial Journey however that looks
like whether it's you keeping it or
selling it I think so too man what a
great legacy to leave and it's going to
clear her debt and leave her better off
for it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsay show you
know George anytime the price of eggs is
making headlines you know you're dealing
with a wacky economy but even news about
layoffs an on-again off-again recession
the crazy high interest rates they're no
reason to give up on your money goals
we're here to give you a plan for your
money join us on the Building Wealth
live tour as we show you how to build
wealth and keep it you can join
personalities like Dave Ramsey we got
George Campbell Rachel Cruz I'll be at
one of those in Indianapolis then on
Down the Line we'll be there in Austin
on February 23rd and next we're heading
to the Building Wealth Salt Lake City
Edition on April 24th and like I said
it's just a mix-up of the personalities
we got Dave we got George we got Rachel
Cruz Christina Ellis myself Ken Coleman
John deloney and finally we're closing
out our tour in Anaheim on May 2nd guys
this is my favorite part tickets start
at just forty nine dollars
and all of our fall Building Wealth
dates are sold out so you don't want to
wait to get your tickets guys go to
ramsesolutions.com events to reserve
your seats for the Building Wealth live
tour let's do this where in the World is
Carmen San Diego but it's Dr John
Delaney which offense you gonna be in
you don't know I see him you don't know
just don't you have to go to the website
and find out it's like the ball that
goes through the cups well people have
been like can't wait to see you in
Anaheim and I'm like oh I won't be there
but say hi to Dr John and Ken for me
it's a great lineup it's I'm really
truly excited for this George it's going
to be great we can't have 19 of us out
there all at once you know that's also
true that's also it's unwieldy
well the phone lines are open give us a
call Triple eight eight two five five
two two five we got Jake on the line and
San Antonio what's going on Jake
hey guys how are you doing we're doing
good how are you
I'm doing wonderful so let me get right
to it my wife and I just got married and
the other night we were doing a budget
and we're trying to combine our finances
and growing up she just you know she's
always been Frugal with her money saves
her money she's excellent with it and
we're just trying to figure out the best
way to
like if we should just put one savings
account and checking account she makes
it very
um she wants to have be able to spend
her money and for me able to be able to
spend my money if we want to buy our own
personal items and we're just trying to
figure out the best way to go about it
yeah I love that I love that you're
having these conversations early and
that you're trying to get on the same
page that's really great
um can I just ask before I go too far
into it you guys have debt at all
so she has zero debt I have 12 000 on a
credit card okay and what's you guys
income looking like
uh right now it's about 112. it's a good
job awesome and you guys have any cash
or anything saved up anywhere for
savings
well and that's another thing I I feel
kind of bad about you know it's not bad
necessarily but guilty because I'm
bringing debt to the table
um right now we probably have about 55
000 cash oh my God that's amazing so why
not just pay off the credit card today
well that's the thing man we just got
married and she I don't expect her to
pay off my debt you know well here's the
thing when you guys got married you you
took all of her and she took all of you
it's not just the Jake that the parts of
Jake I like and the parts that have no
debt do you think she's actually like
hey I don't want to use our my savings
and I work so hard for to pay off your
debt has that been the tone or is she
happy to pay off the debt and set you
guys up for debt freedom
so she wants to be you know I just got
her introduced to you know kind of like
the baby steps and everything I've been
following it for a few months now I've
been paying off because I started about
15 000 maybe a couple months ago and I
just got a slight pay increase
um
so we're doing fine it's just that
you know growing up I think she dealt
with a lot of debt in the household so I
think she was raised not to your debt is
your debt and his debt it's his debt and
it's not like Oh I wanna I wanna have my
money and you should have your money she
is all for combining finances
and that I guess it's two separate
questions because yeah I know we should
just take the the money and pay off the
debt but then do we keep a checking
account where both deposits go into and
then do we each have our own where she
wants to get her nails done or shop for
clothes yeah
that's a great question and you know yes
when you're doing your budget and you're
combining finances I for one do think
that you should have one account where
everything goes in the pot together
right everything's in the pot together
and then when you create your budget
which by the way I suggest in every
dollar budget you can go through and put
your line items on there and you're
taking that all of that income that you
have and you're dividing it up you're
spending every dollar before the month
begins and that's when you can decide
okay yes we both know we're paying the
mortgage we both know we're paying you
know whatever for the cars and we're
paying for our phones but you also get
to put line items in there for the
things that are important to you so like
Jake's haircut or you know your wife's
you know girls night out whatever it is
care self-care fun money fun money yes
you can create those ones yeah you know
you put 100 bucks on there for for fun
money for the two of you split it out 50
50 and you don't have to necessarily say
exactly what you spend it on so there is
some uh Freedom there but at the same
time it's still a shared pot does that
help you at all
it does it does um I really think you
just need to sit down and have a
conversation uh with her about this
because until you do you're just
guessing and my guess is if she values
uh Financial Peace she values frugality
she's probably gonna value you guys
being debt free and until you sit and
ask her about it uh you're really just
guessing so Jake I hope that helps you
thanks for the question if I'm you I
think you guys need to be debt free
today yes and you're still gonna have
plenty of money left over but get one
joint checking account you can have a
savings account attached to that and if
you want to let that money grow you can
put the Savings in an online high yield
savings account to let it grow at you
know three or four percent these days so
that will help you guys get this thing
streamlined and the budget will tell you
how that dollars how those dollars get
spent that's great thanks Jake for the
question all right we got today's
question of the day George are you ready
for this I'm so ready today's question
of the day comes from Ray in California
he says I'm 30 years old make 120k per
here and I don't have any debt I moved
to the USA four months ago and I'm
looking to buy a car I was looking at
used cars initially but the car prices
were 20 000 more as I was looking for
reliable car as the used cars are so
expensive I started looking for new cars
and I finally found a Toyota RAV4 for
30k the monthly payments would be 517 at
an interest rate of 8.5 percent it is
pretty high because I don't have a
credit history here what should I do I'm
planning to refinance my loan after six
months for a lesser interest rate once
my credit gets built and plan to clear
the loan as quickly as possible famous
last words oh my goodness I just keep
thinking of that John Mellencamp song is
like Ain't That America like this guy is
already conforming to this American
culture was like welcome to America how
can we sign you up for payments my
friend with 8.5 interest we did my guy
wrong we did them wrong didn't we George
like he's doing so well he's 30 making
120 000 and doesn't have any debt and
he's already going I want to go take out
a loan oh there's a simple answer here
pay cash my guy and uh the the used car
is 20. yes used cars are are expensive
they're not going to be half the price
necessarily if you want to get a Toyota
RAV4 that's you know a few years used
that's your best bet because someone
else already took the hit on that
depreciation oh yeah
that's never a new car George not when
they lose 60 percent of their value in
the first four years like if they drive
off the lot while you're paying 8.5
interest it's losing percentage points
every day oh and by the way you're on
the hook 517 every month for years and
years draining just draining the wallet
stealing your biggest wealth your
biggest wealth building tool so our
parameters for this on new cars versus
used cars only get a new car and pay
cash by the way if you've got a net
worth of a million bucks or more and the
reason is simple you can afford to take
that hit on depreciation as that car
becomes less and less worthy as you
drive it off the lot it becomes a used
car that's already less a thousand bucks
less than you paid for it I know right
just save up and pay cash my husband and
I we just bought a second car cash and I
gotta tell you we had the money
earmarked for it and when we bought it
it kind of felt like it was free because
we just drove off the lot and it took
eight minutes we just rode in there
wrote a check and got out and that car
ain't getting repo'd You Get It Free and
Clear not a payment in the world and
it's used let me tell you it's used but
it's ours and it's paid for this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's going on you're listening to the
Ramsey Show we're taking your calls
about your life and your money so you
can give us a call here today triple
eight eight two five five two two five
but George before we get to the phone
lines there's something I kind of want
to talk about because I see this a lot
people slide into my DMs and you know
they ask questions about the baby steps
and I have to say by and large the
questions that I get the most actually
have to do with baby step three and I
think what it is
as you you know you've done baby step
one you've gotten your thousand dollars
saved you've done baby step two you've
just like rocked it out right you've
paid off all of your debt and baby step
two and you're thinking you're thinking
like okay baby step three that's gonna
be just just a breeze I'm gonna Breeze
through that finally I get to take all
this money put it back in my pocket and
they are shocked to find out that it's
not as easy as you thought it was gonna
be no and in some ways it's it's hard
can I dare I say I found it to be harder
it was harder most people say they
struggle with this one the most out of
all the baby steps baby step three feels
the most difficult because when you're
paying off debt uh it's fun yep and so
here's how I like to think about it well
it's fun in the sense that you feel the
progress it's addictive you're
celebrating yes okay maybe step three
you're not like another thousand dollars
in the savings account I thought you
should I thought I was gonna feel like
that George but comparatively baby step
two is a thrill and baby step three is a
pill it's the it's just like come on
come on George we already worked so hard
we're tired man we gotta keep up the
side jobs I'm still on the thrill pill
part so let's cover some Basics here
okay when it comes to baby step three we
say it's saving three to six months of
expenses that's a fully funded emergency
fund yep now expenses not income that's
important right this is not this is this
is where people get tripped up because
they're like oh my gosh I have to save
the whole amount of my budget six times
I have to say my whole monthly income
six times that's my about it at all
George right can you break that down
yeah so if you look at your budget not
all of your expenses are mandatory if
there was an emergency if you had a job
loss you had to replace the roof right
you're not going to be living how you
have been living you're not going to be
putting 500 bucks into the sinking fund
for the car no you might cut yourself
subscriptions you might cut some of the
self-care or the fun money and so look
at what your bare bones expenses are for
one month in that budget and you can ask
if you if you're a gym rat and you gotta
you know you can't Skip Leg Day leave
the gym membership in there as part of
your monthly expenses then we can
multiply that number by three four five
six which takes us to the next part Jade
yeah well is it three or six what do I
do well here's the thing you know it
really depends on your lifestyle there's
several things that you want to take
into consideration here if you're single
and it's just your income it's just you
I would do six months because if
something happens you're it you're it
for you right so if you lose your job if
you have something unexpected come up
medical wise it's all on you so let's do
six months for if you're single we want
to think about Health right if you've
got chronic illness in the family I
would lean towards six months if you are
self-employed you're on commission you
have a regular income let's lean towards
six months maybe you have seasonal work
like Landscaping if you're a single
parent I would lean towards six months
that's right if you're married with one
income you might want to leave towards
six months so now the other side of that
flip it to the three month side who
should be saving three months who can
live like that well if you're single and
you have no dependence and you have a
stable income think you know a
government job something where you're
probably not going to get laid off
anytime soon if you're married with two
stable incomes you can lean towards uh
three months so if you're if you are a
teacher and a postal worker you should
be good yep you can lean towards that
three months and sometimes the spouse
may go you know what I'd feel better
saving four then let's say four just do
it don't make it an argument and you
want to know I'll take that a step
further George because I'm the type even
if you're let's say you're like three
three months does it for us but it's
just under what your medical deductible
is I'm like like let's get to the
deductible if the deductible is I don't
know four thousand five whatever your
deductible is I'm like I just like
having that so that I know if anything
happens I know that the savings is there
yes look at all of your insurance
deductibles add those up so your car
insurance your homeowners insurance your
health insurance and that usually is
going to be close to 10 000 or more for
most people it's a lot for me the
minimum for most people in America I'm
saying if you got ten thousand in the
bank you should be good any less than
that and it couldn't put you in a
precarious situation that's right so
where to put this is the next question I
love it not the sock drawer not a tin
can in the backyard buried we've taken
that call this week we sure did so
where's the best place do you want to
keep this liquid do not put it in one of
these CDs don't put it in the stock
market don't invest it I like to put it
in a high yield savings account yes
right now the interest rates have come
way up yeah these are not three four
percent and some of these accounts I
know these are not your 2020 rates you
know what I'm saying these have gone up
and it keeps your cash completely liquid
so at any time you can take this cache
into your checking account without any
fees and penalties and so that's what
you want to look for and if you're more
comfortable having it connected to your
checking account with your local bank
that's fine too the point here is not to
make interest because it's not an
investment your emergency fund is
Insurance not an investment and I like
the high yield savings account because
it gets it out of your normal accounts I
like that it's someplace else it's on a
higher shelf you really got to get on a
stool to get to it you know what I'm
saying you can't just grab it all
willy-nilly like because some people
George have a hard time understanding
what is actually an emergency when do I
spend this money because booboo's
getting married and she's getting
married in the Caribbean and I want to
go that's an emergency the latest iPhone
14 pro Max just came out no more George
not an emergency these things that we're
talking about that's Pro Shops killer
sale does that count no that does not
count here's a tricky One Jade the
dishwasher breaks
you can wash dishes George there is this
amazing thing that you can put it's a
stopper you can put it in the bottom of
the sink and you can actually fill the
sink with water and you can put dishes
in it and wash the dishes with your dad
gum hands George okay did you know
did you know and you want to know what
here's the thing I'm not saying you can
never have a dishwasher again but
couldn't you just cash flow it and
wouldn't it feel nicer because we no one
no one should like to touch their
emergency fund so wouldn't it just feel
nicer if you can every situation you
can't but if you could just hold off and
not move at the speed of sound and at
the speed of light to pay for sub inches
pay cash that's right and there is a few
questions you can ask yourself if you're
going well I'm not sure listen little
Jimmy breaks his arm it's an emergency
yes you get a job loss that's an
emergency car repair that you need to
get to work that's an emergency so ask
yourself these questions is it
unexpected that would be like a sudden
job loss is it necessary like the car
repair and is it urgent like an ER visit
if you can say yes to those questions
then use the emergency fund and don't
have any shame or guilt about it it's
there to be used for emergencies but a
lot of people go oh it hurts to touch it
we work so hard for that I've been there
I have been there it feels you know
especially if you because I know people
listening they're like baby steps like
they do not want to feel like they're
going backward but something happens I
get it all the time on Instagram Jade
our roof something happened with the
roof is there anything that we can do
and people you got to be careful because
people will actually start to consider
debt again oh God instead of because
they're saying their emergency turn to
the HELOC and the credit card and the
401K loan to avoid touching their cash
oh my God and and George you brought it
up so I got it I gotta play devil's
advocate here oh let me do it what did I
do I got to get the right voice
uh George
what about my 401k you know what I'm
saying I could just use my credit card
if something goes wrong I'm gonna just
you know I got a zero percent credit
card that's my that's my that's my
that's my emergency fund right there
George
I would uh say brilliant
good for you bro but you sounded just
like them Jade
it's hard to argue with that kind of a
little bit more you know I'm just gonna
pull out a home equity line of credit
George because I can get it you know I
can leverage my house and I don't have
to anytime someone says the word
leverage I I lose a brain cell oh man oh
my God yeah don't do this you have the
cash to cover it so here's the deal it's
hard to stay motivated in baby step
three it is baby step one 30 days or
less baby step two 18 to 24 months baby
step three is another six months yeah
and you're discouraged there's no
immediate reward like there is with
paying off debt you're in the middle of
the marathon
and uh saving is boring comparatively to
paying off the debt it is and you're
tired of working and can I just throw
this in there you feel like you deserve
it after you've done baby step two you
start being like I did all this I feel I
deserve to pull back on the intensity I
deserve to to go out and buy me some new
clothes you start feeling that keep the
pedal to the metal you're so close and
once you're there listen to this you
have no payments in the world and a pile
of money in the bank to protect you it's
a force field against life you're
finally building for the future instead
of paying for the past we're at baby
step four we're investing for the future
dangle that carrot yes you guys are so
close for those of you that are in baby
step three we are cheering you on we are
here for it I think we need to start
doing baby step three screens come on we
need come on you're almost to the good
part get that money saved you'll be
investing before you know it and before
you know it you'll be saying I'm an
everyday millionaire this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host Jade warshaw sitting next to
me George
[Music]
and we're taking your calls about your
life and your money so be sure to give
us a call today the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
scripture and quote of the day for you
have been called to live in Freedom my
brothers and my sisters but do not use
your freedom to satisfy your sinful
nature instead use your freedom to serve
one another in love Galatians 5 13. I
love that and then Charles Dickens says
this no one is useless in the world who
lightens the burden of another
profound I like it still hits 200 years
later it still hits I love that all
right let's take a couple of calls
George let's go over to AJ in Denver
Colorado what's going on AJ
hey guys thanks for taking my call I
greatly appreciate it absolutely what's
going on I'll just okay so my wife and I
have been super loyal Dave Ramsey
followers ever since we got married we
got gifted uh the uh what is it uh
financial peace
or the baby steps we got gifted the book
and we fell in love with it we have been
dead loyal on the plan like we have our
six-month emergency fund we're invest
[Music]
you have an emergency fund you're
investing and then yep yep we have three
kids
um and we're investing for their college
we have one on the way
um congrats and
we just got our first house last year in
February and we we got it on a 30-year
mortgage uh-oh and uh we basically we
got into a position to where we're like
okay we're gonna make it a 15 year we're
gonna start paying I think it's like an
extra thousand dollars on our mortgage
in order to get it all the way down to a
15-year mortgage and since we have
started doing that
um I I've gotten two pay raises over the
last two years and
um and it equated to sixty thousand
dollars in pay raises and I'm making a
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars a
year that's amazing so what's going on
what's the question today
so the the question is are mortgage
payment uh when you do the calculation
comes out to be 41 of our take home
and at the end of the month we're saving
600 and it'll be around 400 when the new
baby comes and I just want to know what
you guys would do in my situation
because I want to keep the house because
I I was the general contractor on it I
built it and
um my wife's security gland is going off
and she's contemplating you know staying
in it for another year to avoid the
capital gains tax and selling it and to
try and put ourselves in a nicer
financial situation and I just want to
know what you guys would do in my
situation so you're saying you bought
the house with a 30-year mortgage you're
paying it like it's a 15-year mortgage
and by you paying it like it's a 15-year
mortgage it's strapping you because it's
now taking 40 of your of your income is
do I have that straight
Bingo okay so the actual mortgage
payment you have to pay every month is
not 40 percent
it's 26 on okay a year okay okay well I
don't see this as on fire yeah
um obviously it would have been ideal to
do a 15 year where the payment's 25 all
that we're already here and we're
looking to the Future this is not a
thing where I'm like you got to sell the
house you guys have no debt except the
house right
nope none and you're investing 15 of
your income
yep and you're still putting away some
money for kids college and you're still
able to put extra on that yeah your baby
step six
you're just you're just in baby step six
you're chunking towards the house you're
chunking towards paying it off you're
doing you're doing right you know of
course we would have loved if he had
picked a 15-year mortgage that you could
afford to begin with but this is the
hand that you have and I think that
you're playing it beautifully you're
paying as much as you can towards this
now when the baby comes and things get
weird you might have to pull back on how
much that you're putting towards it but
but remember baby steps four five and
six they're about intentionality you
don't have to be duh pedal to the metal
I must do it now you don't have to feel
like that so if you're feeling that
strapped just just ease up a little bit
take a little bit of a breath and and
keep going forward you know there's
plenty of people if you ask us we're
always going to say 15-year fixed
mortgage where the payment is no more
than 25 of your take-home pay we're
always going to say that but there's
plenty of people who got in the game
before they met us you know what I'm
saying and they have a 30-year mortgage
we don't tell those people sell your
house get out of it and go get a 15. we
don't tell them to do that because this
is where they are right now so this is
where you are right now and it's okay
you know so does that make you feel a
little bit better does that make you
sleep easier tonight
yeah it does a little bit like you know
this is the only time that really my
wife and I have had a bit of a like
divide on it you know to where she's
like oh man like I kind of want to sell
it yeah and you know because we want to
go on vacations you know like we want to
we want to do that and and I mean if you
want to we also
if you want to sell the house if you
guys come to that conclusion that you
want to sell the house you can but you
don't need to again and you guys are
going like I said you guys are going ham
paying double on this mortgage you don't
have to pay double on it you know so
from that point on it's really just up
to you again this baby step this baby
step six deal it is not about intensity
it's about being intentional that's a
really great call George I love thank
you for that call AJ so I mean your
actual mortgage payment is not 40 and so
I think reassuring your wife hey we're
gonna be okay we've got an emergency
fund we can make this payment we're
putting extra on this thing we're gonna
pay it off and your income is going to
go up over the next 15 years I'm just
proud of them for being so intentional
it's to the point almost of intensity to
where they felt like oh my gosh we're
not you know hitting this on the head I
I'm just really proud of them they're
going to be all right let's take another
call let's look at Shannon she's in
Tulsa Oklahoma what's going on Shannon
how can we help today yeah hi um thank
you for taking my call guys listen I was
just uh I've been listening a long time
and I have never actually heard uh this
cover this covered on the show and it's
a specific question regarding the I
guess the downtime between baby step
number two getting it everything paid
off with the debt snowball and the
emergency fund so basically in a
nutshell we have a fifteen thousand
dollar emergency fund uh before we
finished baby step two we have a car
payment that is it we just have a car
it's a 23 000 car and um we have 15 000
in the Bank of emergency fund and the
question is we we both know that
following the steps we should be you
know immediately putting 14 000 towards
that car leaving a thousand emergencies
on and then just you know hustling like
crazy to pay that off right the question
though is the problem with it is is we
we are very nervous about giving away
all of our our savings knowing that we
are in a very very busy season with we
have an HVAC that's on its way out
probably this next summer we have a girl
that's going to be a senior in high
school we've got proms we've got senior
pictures we've got trips what's your
household income
thousand uh-huh and uh like I said the
cars the car is 23 of that and that's
our only debt so isn't there a way that
you could knock out this debt and hurry
like hustle hustle up and save up you
know your three to six months
beyond that after you've paid this car
off and then if as other things come
start to cash flow those things as well
we've done the math on what you know if
we if we paid this car if we if we
hustled and got this this car paid off
we've kind of run the math on okay
here's how long we think it because like
I said we've only got 14 to put towards
the 23. so we've done the math on okay
now you know here if we hustle I've
already got a side job so that's already
going uh if we hustle we know it's going
to take us approximately uh eight to ten
months to clear off the rest of the car
from the 14 to the 23 well then that
starts day one of happening to build an
emergency fund back of 15 grand that's
going to take by mass another probably
10 to 12 months so we're putting
ourselves out there 12 months you make
six figures how's it going to take you
that way I don't I think you guys need
to tighten up your budget here there's
some money you guys have a great income
and you need to tighten up your budget
look Shannon I'm not trying to hate on
you but the things that you described
that's just called life that's
everybody's life and I can tell you the
folks that work the baby steps they have
College coming up they have ACS they
have all of the things that you're
talking about and they still choose to
work the plan and you can too it's going
to work out for you all right guys that
does it for today's show be sure to join
us next time and remember this when it
comes to changing your life and your
money you can tell me you won't do it
but please don't tell me you can't with
Christ all things are possible this is
the Ramsay show
what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]